David, if Joe Biden gets elected and Democrats
take the Senate, what will Democrats actually
get done?
So first of all, if Biden wins and Democrats
take the Senate, it's a two year period.
Okay.
Democrats could then lose the Senate in 2022
or lose the House.
We don't know.
There's the low hanging fruit.
And then there's the more complicated stuff.
So certainly Joe Biden will have no choice
but to use executive orders to undo a ton
of Trump's executive orders.
Now, fortunately, many of Trump's executive
orders were just symbolic in nature.
They didn't really do much, but a lot of executive
orders will be needed to stop the damage of
Trump's executive orders that do.
Things I do think that relatively quickly,
a Democratic Senate and Joe Biden would move
to try to undo as much as possible of Donald
Trump's tax reform plan that included handouts
to the very rich and even provisions that
allow Donald Trump to extend his tax loss,
carry forwards indefinitely rather than just
10 or 18 years, however much it was.
But there's a really big question here, which
is that.
Republicans now mean, listen, they stopped
Merrick Garland in 2016 and now they will
probably succeed at putting in Amy CONI Barrett.
They don't care about hypocrisy.
They will obstruct.
They will do whatever Democrats if they win
the Senate.
And Joe Biden winds are going to have to grapple
with what to do about the filibuster, the
filibuster, which requires 60 Senate votes
instead of a simple majority to get a lot
of things done.
And I don't think we are going to see major
legislative action if Republicans really suffer
an embarrassing defeat where Trump is made
a one term president, which is rare in American
politics.
And if Republicans lose the Senate, they're
gonna be hurting and they will get in the
way of anything they can.
I don't see Obamacare being expanded the way
Joe Biden wants without a 60 votes.
And there's no way that they're going to get
60 votes.
So the question will be, do they get rid of
the filibuster?
I don't see the truck, Joe Biden's clean energy
plan going anywhere.
If it depends on, you know, a Senate that
is 52 to 48 in favor of Democrats, if that's
what it is.
So if Democrats take control of the Senate
and they rewrite the filibuster rules, then
you may see more action done.
Now, are they going to do that?
It's risky.
Barack Obama alluded to it at the funeral
of John Lewis.
That's probably the highest profile support
we've seen of getting rid of the filibuster.
But understand that whatever Democrats imagine
that it takes, I don't know, eight to 12 months
of Joe Biden's first term to get rid of the
filibuster.
And then Democrats get something done in the
second year of Joe Biden's first term.
And then imagine that Republicans take back
the Senate and maybe even the House, we don't
know, in 2022.
You have opened the door for Republicans to
use the lack of a filibuster to do ungodly
things.
So this is always the question is, does it
start a race to the bottom?
I don't know the answer.
But if somehow Democrats figured out a way
to get the votes, I believe the priorities
would be to deal with coronavirus relief in
a more serious manner if depending on when
that happens.
Expand Obamacare in the way that Joe Biden
wants to do.
New tax reform plan.
Clean energy.
Those would be the four that I see the most
likely that Democrats would want to tackle
if given the opportunity.
Again, depending on what degree of a majority
do they have in the Senate or do they get
rid of the filibuster?
One last thing, without getting rid of the
filibuster.
Democrats could still get things done if they
take the Senate, even if it's only 51, 49,
52, 48.
But they will have to concede a ton to Republicans.
They will have to pass their bills with these
horrifying, disgusting amendments that they
put in there in order to get some Republican
votes.
Is the country better off if that's what they
do?
I don't know.
You've really got to look at the specifics.
We've got a great bonus show for you today
with producer Pat Forde.
We will be back next week with the regular
show, the bonus show.
And the vice presidential debate is next week,
Carmela.
I think she's going to crush, crush, crush
Mike Pence.
We'll see you next week if you're not a member.
If you are a member.
Enjoy the bonus show coming up right after
this.